the Lebanese armed group Hezbollah is
promising a response for the
assassination of hamas's number two
Salah Al arui along with a number of
military commanders and Hamas members
they were killed in that apartment as
you can see this was a surgical strike
Israel did not claim responsibility but
it is believed to have been responsible
for killing those men who were
apparently holding a meeting now this is
a security breach Israel acting on
intelligence Hamas of course an ally of
Hezbollah it has really developed a
military infrastructure in this country
um with the support and help of
Hezbollah and Hezbollah is calling this
a serious assault on Lebanon and that it
is also a dangerous development in the
ongoing conflict between is Israel and
the axis the so-called axis of
resistance now Hezbollah has joined the
Battle of against Israel to help relieve
Hamas and Gaza there have been rockets
that have been fired from Syrian
territory towards Israel uh the houis in
Yemen they have been firing drones and
missiles at Israel all these different
fronts uh trying to relieve pressure on
Hamas in Gaza so in hezbollah's
statement they are alluding to the
possibility of um an escalation on all
these fronts because hezbollah's
response it it it is in a difficult
position because if its response
triggers a full-blown conflict with
Israel then it will face um opponents in
Lebanon and being it will also be
accused of dragging Lebanon into
conflict and if Hezbollah does not
respond then its credibility is at stake
because even before uh the conf conflict
began along the border uh the South
Lebanon border Hezbollah has had
promised that any assassination of a
Lebanese a Palestinian and Iranian
official in Lebanon will elicit a fierce
uh reaction now tomorrow the head of
Hezbollah Hassan nah he was he's planned
to give he's he's expected to give a
planed speech uh late on Wednesday to
coincide with the fourth anniversary of
the killing of the head of the Iranian
kudus Force kasum SU
what will he say all eyes really are on
Hezbollah but no doubt this is a major
blow to hamas's um military
infrastructure in Lebanon Israel
believes that Hezbollah will respond but
it will stop short of of of dragging the
country or or dragging this into a full
full-blown War what Hezbollah has been
doing so far in the South really has
been calibrating its actions um this is
no doubt a serious escal
and a turning point Z alaz the southern
suburbs of
Beirut make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer